the stain on my pants come on you can
cover that with your hands or the stain
gentlemen how are you doing fantastic
good very good just talking about the
wonderful hair comparisons here Yeah
right it's good I mean all three of you
kind of are in there bring me into this
when is the new album coming out that's
a good question app tomorrow man that's
tomorrow
trick people yes no doubt tomorrow we
are gonna put it out next year
okay because we need time to pull
together the creative and pull all songs
together mm-hmm and honestly there's a
little bit of it and think of a name
yeah we're never named and yeah I think
we're gonna release a few more songs
before we fully understand yeah is it
done
yeah 90 90 to 95 percent done the the
extra is sort of 5% that needs to happen
is it tedious or is it actually work you
enjoy doing it just includes us being
back home because we're on tour for a
couple more months which we have a show
today if there's yep today which is
going to be great but once we get back
we'll name the album we'll finish it and
it will be out early next year you know
the reason why there is no name
currently is that you have not all
decided or there's infighting about the
name what's happening with the name it
kind of comes lost the name for us yeah
and we name it lost or it could be based
off a song that particularly is a suited
to being you know the title that the
album and got to be good yeah it needs
to define a lot of things yes yeah and
when you are doing shows are you playing
new stuff are you introducing stuff
during these shows the purposes of these
shows are playing with the chainsmokers
as you know hopefully how it does we
we're playing the new songs that are out
but nots not needing your songs off the
album I think will release a new song
again soon
but what kind of just playing like it's
it's really good said actually it's a
like a mix of kind of f3 albums and then
two new songs that we have and they're
kind of all jumbled up and it's like a
mash-up of song is really cool it's good
what sort of expectations do you guys
put on yourselves because there's the
creative side of it then there's the biz
side of it and when you have an album
that have outpaced Beyonce outpace jay-z
that's some serious success where you
start talking about that kind of thing
when it comes to the success of an album
when you guys are putting a new one
together does that weigh on you guys at
all that it has to be great artistically
but it still has to be successful and is
that a different formula it depends what
you value yourself as an artist I think
we don't really talk about those things
very much because they mean a lot to a
consumer frame of mind but it we find it
to be toxic to the creative process so
we don't really ever talk about things
like that yeah but and also it's it
makes music sound competitive and I
don't be that guy but it's not so you
know I often talk about the Beyonce and
jay-z thing cuz they they were actually
really brave in the way they approached
that they tried to release music on
their own platform and I think that's an
incredible thing to do I mean we didn't
have the balls to do that yeah we
released it now everybody else releases
music and they have been genius enough
to come up with their own way of
releasing music on their own platform as
businesswomen and businessman and I
think that's so cool
but you know on this next record we've
had three number-one albums in the US
and potentially here I'm not sure but we
have awesome listeners and they're more
diverse than ever so we're focused on
reaching out to the broader audience
that we haven't had before and appeasing
the people that do listen to our music
already I think I think the pressure
comes less from like the numerical value
of what it is to make an album and I
think we just you know every time we go
in to create new music as long as we go
in with the mindset if we want to create
something better than what we've done
before then I guess we hope that the
rest will kind of follow suit you know
as they thought was what happened with
us on the lost record we just we just
went into it being like we just want to
make the best music that we can make
like we don't care what happens like
charts and like
whatever else under that umbrella if we
were just like we want to make the best
music that we can possibly make and see
as many people around the world as
possible and then kind of the other
stuff followed which is amazing but even
if it didn't I think we'd be just as
proud to release the same music you know
even going forward into this album we're
not we don't care about whatever that is
it's just as long as we know that we've
made the best album that we can make
that's what matters and we have it's
like albums very oh yeah okay
collaborations are huge right now with
chainsmokers do you guys have a list of
people that you would love to
collaborate with it's more the reason
you say yes yeah it's more of them so
you look at where music is that in the
modern modern time frame and we try to
challenge people's perspective of what a
young kind of rock group can do because
they're we're kind of a dying breed I
think and it just takes really precise
and out-of-the-box maneuvers
feature-wise or collaboration wise to to
make people think in a different way
about what bands can do and the
potential of what you can put an act
like us I also think a lot of people
like collaborating with us because we
are abandoned we'll really perform their
songs live to a standard that would make
them proud of it yeah
so yeah there's a lot of benefits to the
collaboration and collaborative process
is that why people want you guys in
Shawn Mendes so bad because he's a great
guitar player he is now yes I remember
meeting Shawn a couple years ago and he
was learning stitches in his dressing
room on acoustic guitar it's crazy to
see him play now cuz he has these
incredible mentors like John Mayer and
we really we appreciate him especially
when we come to Toronto we we see him
everywhere in the Tim Hortons
commercials and stuff and it's it's
crazy to see and that's what we do love
about Canada you really embrace your ex
and you you hold them up and give them a
fair go on the world stage which is cool
how old were you guys when all this
started
like started started like 15 to 17 or
something around all of you around yeah
yeah dealing with sort of Fame now are
you happy that you've had time to sort
of grow with your fans and grow into the
sort of people that you are as opposed
to having to deal with the hardcore
stuff at yeah I think the key is just be
patient with yourself like any other
being famous just a life challenge just
like anything else like getting up going
to work
you can't up here yeah I think you got
to remain flexible and patient with your
own being and what you actually want
from your life and I think famous you
can be you can look at it in many ways
but for us we just look at it with a
friendly approach and people like us and
they like what we do and they like our
music I think when you start to
overthink things like that you'll have
an overgrown ego and become lost within
yourself and maybe lost in a version of
yourself that used to exist so we always
try to be now and hear and enjoy what
we're doing and enjoy the things that
have been bestowed upon us because of
hard work right and dealing with fans
and dealing with Twitter I've talked to
a lot of people where it doesn't matter
how famous you are one bad tweet can
ruin a day yeah I guess maybe especially
at the stop for us it's kind of a thing
less like oh I don't know why you feel
that way you like you haven't really met
me but at this point it's not I like
that it's not really a thing that is
bothersome anymore you know we meet it's
funny because we meet fans like every
especially on tour like in every city
and there's nothing but love out there
and you know as people without like
tattoos about lyrics and like all the
artistic stuff and people like we love
your music we love you know you playing
on stage and that's all that really
matters to us yeah the negative stuff is
interesting because it's kind of the
best promotion you could ever have yeah
I think that's what negative people
don't realize when they see you stuff at
us it's like it's kind of helping us
right yeah it's almost like a good thing
like it's cool you can change your
mindset to look at it that way because
it's like more people are talking about
us
and yeah yeah people that wouldn't
normally talk about us if you don't like
us then you're just kind of promoting us
and no that's true in it and it
sometimes it takes something like
sticking up for a girlfriend on Twitter
to realize the compassion that then
follows when people realize how awful
somebody can be hmm right yeah I mean I
just it's a thing that's you know happen
for a while I just felt the need to kind
of say something about it because it
affects my everyday life you know it's
funny that it's the same thing it's uh
it's it's just words on screen can be
pretty can be like pretty proud when you
forget that I suppose but you know just
trying to keep the peace and keep
everyone happy and keep my you know real
life in order if that makes sense and
trying to keep that like a positive
space and not affected by you know all
that negative stuff but you could fight
all the fights which would take up your
entire life if that's what you want
right would never do that
I think that's a good thing about the
people who are fans of our group they're
they'll do that yeah they do yes that's
funny they do it like us even yeah doing
anything yeah I think we're we're good
people and we have these really good
people that follow our group so we don't
really um encourage or pay attention to
the negative stuff sure and when it does
come to touring you're not home you're
on the road do you love playing live but
dislike touring or do you actually still
enjoy the process of touring that's a
good question I like that one because
it's interesting because it's like
playing the actual show is the best part
of the entire day like that's what you
look forward to it's like sort of the
other parts of it where you know you'll
be stuck in like the middle of I don't
know I don't know runner has no suck but
um that's nice
got that but you know what I mean it's
like playing the show is kind of what
the entire day builds up to and the rest
of it is like this so much waiting
around in what we do it's like you
travel city to city to city and you just
like wait all day to go on and play the
show and you travel to fantastic places
that you can't see mmm sometimes yeah
you got to make an effort as well
because there's definitely times that ya
Michael's right a psycho cheese with
like traveling so I'm a swore like
traveling like all the time and like
you're in a new city every day and then
it's like you can have the mindset of
like oh no but then it's like oh we're
traveling everywhere and we're in a new
city every day it's like you can look at
it two ways and sometimes you know
you're bit more like negative about it
and some days you're more positive about
it you trying to keep you know more
positive it's weird we look at I often
look at the age where at and I'm like
what are people our age doing who aren't
in a group or a band or and most of them
are students so you be a student because
you know this is your classroom and
right now it's you get to evaluate what
your life is and what's important what
isn't important what you don't know and
what you should know and you just act
like a student still you learn well I
mean today it's like you know we're
talking about for instance in this
interview it's like you're talking about
the effects of something like Fame or
you're talking about online persona and
how that affects your real life it's
like you know these are all case studies
really you got it and you look at them
in a positive way and you work them out
and you and you hopefully I don't know
affect people positively in some way I
don't know but we just kind of make sure
we're remaining curious and alert to
things that are happening in our life
and be curious about the places we go
you